TV coverage of e3 2014 my name is Daniel
Dwyer and I'm very happy to be joined
with Julian Garrity how's it going ad on
Andrew from reflections well from
reflections and from ivory tower I agree
South ivory tower in front you guys are
doing a hot collabo on the crew yes and
I'm very happy to hear the reflections
are involved because driver san
francisco is a was a game that surprised
me normally its credit legal game i
think i'm not sure if it's fair to say
that was surprised me but i guess it was
it's the best driver game but it's
pretty great hey so you guys are here
with the crew yeah this game it's been
shot around for a little while and it's
it's a type of driving game that i guess
now people are starting to get familiar
with because driving and the idea of
social driving seem to be hand in hand
regardless of what the franchise is so
what is it about the crew that makes it
stand out from from other driving games
what I think I'm this social driving
aspect is something that the Eden team
which did GD you test drive unlimited
pioneered on 360 I mean this is eight
years ago that those guys did that and
that was a fully open world seamless
experience and this is the second or
third iteration on that so it's built
from the ground up with the social
interactions so you want to create a
crew that's two clicks once you meet
somebody in the world and that person
will become part of your crew proud of
your friends list and you can play with
those guys whenever but I think more
than that what makes the stand out is
the fact that we have the entire USA
which is it's not all about size I kept
telling myself it's not all about bank I
keep telling myself gives me up a
nightmare keep Tony it's about variety I
don't know what that said says about me
but you like to mix it up that's all
right absolutely it's it's more about
the different driving experiences that
you can have so one of the things that
we have and that we really really want
to put out there at e3 this year is
off-road racing in as found racing
circuit racing all of these different
types of driving and handling
experiences and that's really what makes
us stand out eighty percent of our
country is off-road yeah yeah so that
that really is the difference between an
open-world ray
sir a little bit like driver san
francisco absolute so anyway the game
that we have it's interesting that this
is a team that worked on TDU because
oftentimes you think about the idea of
social gaming the the touch point of
people talk about is burnout paradise
but in fact that such a limited predate
stuff and did a lot of innovations in
that space that I guess we're incredibly
new the stuff that people did not
realize they wanted in a driving game
absolutely is there anything allu in
that in the crew are you guys tackling
the idea of this this for player
experience from any other different
types of angles that we're used to in
driving games so one thing that I'm
passionate about is giving an experience
to people that they can play any way
that they want so I'm more of a single
player guy and in drive to San Francisco
was exactly my jam because it was
exactly the type of game I wanted to
play but even burnout paradise I played
mostly single player it's where I'm
comfortable so i'm working with a game
direct and i think Andy's very similar
who like multiplayer experiences you
like sharing this experience so every
single mission that we have in the game
every single race or take down or get
away from the cops is playable not only
solo but cooperatively and that's quite
apart from the 70 or 80 other PvP or
crew vs crew competitive missions that
we have yeah is that the way you feel
about it yeah absolutely i mean it was
like it's a tremendous opportunity to
work with you know some of the original
guys from TD u cuz he was a passion of
mine when i was playing on the 360 it
was it was the game and then to get to
work with the guys was like wow since
you guys reflections even like going
back to their the original driver was a
game that came out on on ps1 i remember
the day I bought it yeah and like three
different cities that felt like real
places and you guys have been
consistently good at that I think that
driver san francisco was interesting in
in that respect as well that it felt
like a real place one of the criticisms
I might have the chest I've the
unlimited games is that they were maybe
not criticism but it those games felt
like they were sandbox for the player
you weren't trying to evoke this
particular place or time but it's not
very much like was a bad drive so it's
always important to fill it you know
it's okay it's as we say its size is
important to hear the scale is important
for
tdu I looked about that was the emergent
gameplay yeah was you know a lot of the
stuff like you know we should take
Koenig's eggs we had a club we're called
the Black Knights we had black
Lamborghini Gallardo's I used to just
drive around and we look for someone who
sinks into our session and we'd kind of
pincer move them to the edge of a cliff
and then push them off this is this is
the horror that is the horror night
makes me see you in a hole we had like
match it was perfect but it's that
emergent fun you know that we used to
take Koenig's eggs for the top of
mountains and now with the crew we have
a specialist kit which allows us to take
passed the top of Mount yes genuinely
it's all driver that's right but coming
back to your point about that the soul
of a place the the spirit of San
Francisco if you will I think in test
drive unlimited that was also due to the
fact that it was Hawaii yeah and not
Hawaii has an ambience but it's more a
paradise feels no it's it's a little
superficial it felt a little intangible
or so yeah what we did on the crew was
we wanted to find a solution to that so
you know we did a lot of research trips
that were very tough going to Miami
going I set the team to Detroit hahaha
but I took care of New York Miami Los
Angeles but that that for me was really
a part of how can we make these
different cities feel completely
different and it comes through in the
architecture comes throwing the size of
the streets comes through in the art
direction so I think we've done a better
job on that for the croup well it's a
well I'm excited but just when you came
up you know you told me borrow your from
I'd no idea that this collaboration was
happening and their two franchises that
I've I both loved but also ones that I
wanted to see more from fantastic cool
so there's a lot more in the crew I
think this is going to be what about 5-6
times bigger than test drive unlimited
yeah how much bigger than san franpsycho
invent a number yeah I'm veneman I'll
say it's infinitely bigger than
infinitely big yeah like a no man's sky
driving
yeah that's a good quote can I ask you a
really boring question if you wanted to
drive from Miami to Los Angeles there
from New York or how long could it take
if you're in a medium range car hey it's
a very good question okay what we show
during the e3 briefing with our trailer
and it's time lapse trailer so yeah it's
very cool Gino white little secret we
came to e3 so unprepared with we're
closing the game so we have to finish
things yes for hands we don't have time
to mess around with a specific trailer
or specific demo so we had to bring what
we have that's the best and that's the
game so we got a guy at a team of guys
actually there were four guys to do one
afternoon of just rushing through the
states from Miami New York Rockies San
Francisco whatever and in an afternoon
they captured that and we cut it
together and that is about two and a
half hours by rip we accelerated it
because I wanted to do a two and a half
hour trailer but he stuff wasn't having
you know their presentations expensive
it's expensive time expensive minute so
that's excellent 290 those look like
fast cars as well Soto k cos if you're
just doing Los Angeles New York yeah in
the fastest car in the game it's about
45 minutes an hour sticking to the roads
but of course off-road vehicle it's
going to be a much longer trip so let's
talk about obviously one of the really
interesting things different types of
racing different types of terrain and
whatnot specifically the different types
of races and activities you tell us like
is it is a lots of laughs races is a
lots of distance racing or whats in
there I've got all kinds in there with
you know over a thousand different
activities to engage you with on this on
this massive road trip I mean one of the
things that were showing off as well as
giving people a chance to see some of
the skills which we've got in the world
which Julian mentioned in the press
conference on Monday but and this is
stuff which is that emerged in front
it's like wouldn't it be cool if I just
climbed this mountain side or weave
through these trees and we're trying to
make fun out of that and make them
instantly replayable as well so it's you
know 30 to 45 seconds blast and you go
yes um and and you do it and you set a
ghost time and then you
and compete with each other and it's
cool because we all kind of need that
asynchronous multiplayer these days well
I know for one I do it's like you know
time becomes valuable and your friends
have children and game night becomes one
night a week instead of every night one
night I'm I would say yeah yeah you
feeling it yeah you have kids I don't
know yeah I've got kids so I can only
play at six in the morning sorry up at
six in the morning asynchronous who goes
okay super important to you and you know
we see the game as different challenges
for the different amount of time that
you can invest in it so you remember
project gotham racing away even before
that MSR and the kudos system so we've
got that for that micro loop of game
plays just for combos that you're
chaining together to get to earn a
little bit of cash the skills that Andy
was talking about we pepper those around
the world there over 500 very varied
from Hill Climb to slalom challenges to
precision challenges where you have a
gate it gets smaller and smaller go to
follow challenges Racing apex line
challenges lots of different things like
that plus you've got missions and the
missions are basically racist and we
have a story in the game it's not
Shakespeare as I like to say I'm not
gonna tell you it's gonna shock you it's
gonna change the world again nah it's
it's a light frothy story it is it a
means to getting the player to
experience all these different exactly
it's a means and narrative glue is the
game you get the more think on a road
trip round the USA it basically takes
you on road trip so it gives you
structure some games some open world
games that lacking matt structure and
you kind of get bored and directionless
after a little too sometimes when
there's so much to choose from like I
had a Sanskrit black flag for instance
when there's so much to choose from you
don't you don't have a little bit of
direction you don't know where you
should go so it's finding that right
balance you and those missions there are
70 80 in the game and they they vary so
it could be lab races it could be street
races that are point-to-point could be
rattling races could be getaways from
cops it could be takedown
okay there's a lot of variety and we're
crossing that with the different
terrains so your takedown could be a
takedown in the city streets in Miami
but it could also be a takedown across
the beaches of the Great Lakes and so
we're trying to mix things up everybody
knows the limits of a traditional
driving game yeah true so we're really
trying to push that with the different
types of vehicles customizations that
we've got there too yeah so yeah let's
talk about that a bit so obviously we've
talked about the different types of
races seem like you guys have indeed try
to create a lot of variety anyway
because one of the problems of driving
games is that they're largely a known
quantity now another thing that a lot of
people are asking on Twitter earlier
today when I said you guys were going to
reinspect was how much that'll driving
crew and fans I got getting in here but
less specific than that was just
generally car customization yeah yeah an
ownership because that's a big thing
about TD you is like it's almost like
polishing your Carm you know making sure
that it's set up the way you want how
deep do you go in on that and also with
a game are you spanning an entire
country where you keep your cars it's a
really good question that there are
three questions there for me I don't
want to get too intellectual but it's
this French side of me I'm like
philosophically now philosophically
we're approaching this game with real
ownership in mind so when I play the
game I take one car and I stick with it
for 20 hours and improve it and increase
its capacities because we are an RPG at
the end of the day so there are 11
performance parts and I'm upgrading each
part to make sure that I blow all of my
friends and crew members off the road
the customization is really along two
lines first one is we've got different
car classes and much like an MMORPG as
well you start off with a street with
your paladin and get your face not quite
as well-defined as that isn't more along
the lines of half what's the driving
sensation that you're going to get so
just three of our five classes Street
which is street racing very very good
handling pretty good speed built for as
well then you've got dirt which is more
of a rally type handling nice drifts
really fun on dirt tracks
and then my favorite which is raid which
is what we've just seen here okay it's
just pure offroad if you remember
smugglers run yeah it's my favorite game
or one of my favorite games this is
basically i love letters to smugglers
run so those are the classes and you can
take one car and make it evolved from
one class to the next so you're this Han
370 Z Z I'm so k Irish it's ryan says
that's correct 370 said and you can make
it evolve from a streetcar to rate card
so the manufacturers have allowed us to
do crazy customization kits on those I
shouldn't say that because they're
probably here but what manufacturers do
you have actually all right where we
split between three different categories
American Muscle both classic and
contemporary so Mustang dodge charges
things like that European luxury Bentley
Maserati is marriage dorati official or
not is now I think we best stop stop
talking about four original members
quickly on what's a Ferrari we announced
yesterday or the day before yeah she's a
big time for ass Lamborghini of course
as the Martin excellent and Japanese
cars so you know miss an R GTR a lot
okay a loss okay I think it's incredible
because I think that sort of licensing
is often reserved for games opinion the
simulation genres a while yeah you guys
obviously not necessarily being an
arcade racing game but not necessarily
being a sim game either that's right why
didn't you to smash them up Hagan is so
are they allowing you to smash them up
yeah we do have a damage model where you
know we opened up the doors to the
community that's one of the things that
we've been doing in the final stretch
and they've given us a lot of positive
feedback they love certain things and
certain things are being criticized as
one and i'm pretty open about it and one
of the things that they were talking
about was okay the damage model isn't
visible again so we've got to find that
right balance between pleasing your vice
Lamborghini and getting something that
gamers want to see real damage on I
think we're gonna have something that's
that's fairly impressive along those
same lines as driver exist
back to gameplay you know it's like it
there's no point destroying a car to the
point of destruction when you just can't
use it yeah you've got to strike that
fine line between fun best you when you
realize when you're driving that far as
well last question utley one-word answer
maku's who asks will the next will the
sequel to the crew be the entire planet
can we finish this game okay please is
it not finish a closing its due date and
Andrew thank you so much for coming on
super funny let us know and when the
cruisers on our moi platforms yes
November 11 same days a couple of other
big titles but the crew is the one that
matters and we're coming out on ps4 xbox
one and pc excellent thank you so much
for joining us here unless I'm some
stage at gamespot com really appreciate
it thanks I we've got more Ruby soft
stuff coming up we got tom clancy's the
division up in just a couple of minutes
so stay here on gamespot com